colombia continúa sufriendo la espiral
de violencia provocada por las masacres
y en ellas los jóvenes siguen siendo los
principales afectados este viernes otras
tres personas de entre 14 y 27 años
grandes localidad del departamento de
antioquia en las últimas tres semanas
hasta nueve masacres han sacudido
diferentes zonas del país el 11 de
agosto fue la primera de estas masacres
en cali seguida de otras dos en nariño y
de tres masacres más entre el 20 y el 21
de agosto que causaron 16 víctimas
muchas de estas zonas son rutas clave
para el narcotráfico la última masacre
tuvo lugar mientras el presidente acudió
a cali tras la detención de dos
sospechosos de la matanza del 11 de
agosto a 5 adolescentes en esta ciudad
duke prometió justicia después de que su
gobierno recibiese duras críticas en las
últimas semanas
aquí el que la hace la tiene que pagar y
vamos a seguir esclareciendo estos
crímenes y vamos a seguir encontrando a
los culpables pero se requiere además
que la sanción que dé la justicia sea
ejemplar y sant a casi cuatro años de la
firma del acuerdo de paz colombia ve
como el fenómeno de las masacres que
padeció el país durante décadas está
regresando con fuerza en este 2020 a
pesar de los cinco meses de cuarentena
por la pandemia de coronavirus algo que
hace que ese tema que la paz pueda
descarrilar definitivamente